[Music]
carolina hey dana how are you
hey thanks for taking my call sure how
can i help how can we help
um so my son um he's 21 he graduated in
december
um he has not been able to find a job
and i've been helping him
um with his bills he was in florida what
kind of uh
what kind of degree did he get he got a
degree in game art
in what in game art he's an artist
game art as in like uh like
video games yes okay oh okay cool
all right so he's got a lot he's got a
lot of graphic arts under his
digital graphic arts under his belt then
right yes
yeah so maybe he's not and maybe he
doesn't go to work for a game company
maybe he goes to work for a company
yes okay all right
um but i've been helping him out and i
really can't anymore
um and i just want to know how to go
about that letting him know that
without ruining our relationship your
relationships only based on money
no i just i just don't want to upset him
because i've been helping him out so
much
so first and foremost you're gonna have
to put that down
um and if the truth about my mom's
financial situation
impacting my inability to find work
like if that is if yeah as dave just
pointed out if that's what my love for
my mom is based on
there's other deeper problems i think
you take him out to breakfast and say
hey i've done the math on my own budget
and i can't keep doing this
here's the finish line here and i know
your dream is to work for pixar i know
your dream is to work for
i don't know what i'm going to make up
games fortnite or whatever the thing is
um
those are animal farms that's one you
like yeah dude i don't know
for pong that's the last video game i
played atari um surely they've yeah
um you're on your own you're gonna have
to go find work
he's a 21 year old college grad and he
is
lived under somebody who loves him and
who's given him a soft place to land
after graduation particularly
in a coveted mess but how much money
have you been giving him
um well he lives out of state so i've
been helping with everything um anywhere
from six to eight hundred a month
800 a month okay and you've reached the
end of being able to do that you're
saying how much longer
could you do that probably not anymore
not at all you're out of money no
okay so it really doesn't matter you
just got to
um tell him because you can't give him
more money you're just done
right okay so yeah my suggestion have
breakfast isn't going to work so
yeah but it's a facetime conversation
yeah just but just get on the phone or
facetime or whatever and
just say you know i i've i'm so sorry
i've reached the end of my money i don't
have any more
and so you're gonna have to you know go
do something so you're six or eight
hundred he's not surviving on that
well he has he lives with other people
so they split rent
so his rent's like 200. so he doesn't
work at all
no he hasn't like not delivering pizzas
or uber or
not mowing grass or blowing leaves or
anything
not that i'm aware of not that i know
okay yeah that ends today
when i asked him he said he's been
looking videos yeah
i promise when he gets hungry enough um
i would go pick up anything and
everything honey it's what i had to do
when i was your age
and um i love you i'm cheering for you
i'll do everything i can to help you i
just don't have any more money i'm so
sorry i'm out and it breaks my heart i
wish i could help more but i can't
and if he gets mad about that that is on
him okay is he going to give him a hand
is he is he a person that gets mad at
his mother no i mean i don't think i
don't think he i did okay
all right i just don't want him to like
if he was my son
i would have already had this discussion
about six months ago
and we would have been delivering pizzas
go down to home depot buy a leaf blower
rich people are afraid of leaves
you can get a job i mean there's stuff
to do okay and dana
you're a good mom you are a great mom
you're a good mom you're a great mom
mom the level of your
mother of the year award is not based on
dollars
ever you're a good mom dan this is the
dave ramsey show